I do is we're going to take this
polynomial here we're going to divide it
by X minus 2 and we're going to write it
as the divisor times the quotient plus
the remainder so I want to show you a
method to help you remember you know how
to set this up and understand why it
works so let's just take a simple
numerical example like say we had 20
divided by 6 right so we say how many
times does 6 go into 20 well it goes in
there 3 times 3 times 6 is 18 and
remainder is 2 right so if we want to
get back to 20 which is like in this
case like our original polynomial what
do we do well we take 6 times 3 okay
which is our divisor times our quotient
so 6 times 3 is 18 plus the remainder 2
gives us back the original 20 so we have
divisor times the quotient plus the
remainder gives us back our original
polynomial sorry with me so far so let's
go ahead and do that in this problem so
what we're gonna have is we're gonna
have we're dividing by X minus 2 so when
you do this synthetic division you take
the opposite sign here so if it's X
minus 2 you're gonna put positive 2 here
if it's X plus 2 you're gonna put a
negative 2 if you want to see more about
synthetic division I'll put a link in
the description below to a video I did
talk about how to do synthetic division
we've got 3x to the fourth 0x cubed 2x
squared 5x and negative 1 so I put a 0
in for a placeholder since we didn't
have any x cubed terms so here what I'm
going to do is I'm going to bring down
the 3 I'm gonna multiply in the diagonal
add straight down multiply on the
diagonal add straight down multiply on
the diagonal add straight down multiply
in the diagonal add straight down this
last number here 65 that's our remainder
and so what we want to do now is we want
to write our quotient quotient is our
answer because we started off with 3x to
the fourth this is going to be 3x cubed
it goes down by one degree okay and this
is a remainder so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take our polynomial P of X
is equal to our divisor which is what
we're divide anybody that's going to be
the X minus two times our quotient
quotient is our answer that's this here
3x cubed plus 6x squared plus 14x
plus 33 plus a remainder the 65 and you
can double-check you're working on this
if you want you just have to multiply
these two polynomials together add the
remainder 65 you're going to get the
original polynomial back which is this
quantity up here so great job again if
you want to see more about synthetic
division check out the video I did right
there otherwise I look forward to
helping in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon